[Music]
so um you guys know about the uh the
freedom convoy in canada yeah
i know that they're full of hate hate
for trudeau uh nah that's not what i
heard
i heard they flew a swastika i heard
they're violent protesters and they're
fighting people i heard they had a
confederate flag i heard they're a part
of the alt-right and they're
anti-vaxxers
and actually um i heard that they're all
vaccinated and they're just like hey we
wanted you we want the choice
to
interesting to vaccinate you know that's
what i heard that's what i heard too
they just want to not have the mandates
and let it be a choice for people
there's actually a lot of vaccinated
truckers that are just like wait because
wasn't it messing up the trade laws or
like making it difficult yeah they just
couldn't work it [ __ ] with their
entire livelihood wow well uh there was
a gofundme that was created in support
of the freedom convoy and go fund me
just uh suspended and cancelled the
fundraising account wow
after it already raised a million
dollars in support whoa
that's crazy do they get all that back
to everybody else refund no they don't
they don't get it well if you donated
you have until a specific date to get
your money refunded back to you if you
don't uh just steal it they're not going
to automatically refund it they are
going to redistribute it to a different
charity
that the freedom convoy um wants it to
go to
but that charity also has to be approved
by gofundme why did they take it away
from them because apparently in the
terms of service of gofundme which i
don't know if this is like a new change
or whatever they believe that uh if if
um a fund
seems like it is gonna result in an
unlawful or violent occupation
then you're not allowed to uh to have
yeah cause they don't wanna go fund like
the isis or something yeah it's like hey
help us like
jihad our [ __ ] you know yeah i think
it was the uh the categorization of its
change from being some sort of like
peaceful convoy to suddenly like an
occupation because they were like
outside of like canada's like capitol
hill or whatever and blocking or yeah
you know what i mean so but isn't that
what what protest is i thought protest
was what you know what they did when
occupy wall street like went to um
they were in wall street right and they
were like hanging out in that area like
nobody was like that's [ __ ] up yeah i
mean wall street was
was there any any moment of potential
violence or anything that happened no
the thing is that uh there might have
been different like uh
there could have been different
incidents but
basically there was pressure from uh
from trudeau
on gofundme to like kind of not to cut
this off
and uh
essentially that's what happened because
gofundme says oh we received information
from the police
that this
peaceful
protest is turning
is there me i haven't i haven't keeping
up on the media with this because like i
don't really
know what's truth or not right now media
but um
is there proof of violence happening
because i hear rumors of like yeah
there's like people fighting and
violence but then like there's no video
of so people say that the truckers went
into like this area where they used they
they feed homeless people and that
truckers were violent there and that
they jacking like we're jacking food
there but then the truckers say that i
mean a couple of people
um were told that they could eat the
food there and then
um somebody
at the um who was feeding the homeless
people didn't recognize that this
trucker wasn't a homeless person and
they fed them and then a bunch of
truckers thought that you could get
eaten
so that's the counterpoint but i don't
know what the truth is so how's that
violence i don't know well
so far it sounds like nothing's really
going on at this thing that hasn't gone
on in a lot of these protests it kind of
seems like okay it's a [ __ ] protest a
lot of shit's going hey those outliers
yeah so far the only thing i've seen is
this comparison of uh this versus like
some of the blm protests
where it's uh
i guess it's supposed i don't know too
much about it but i guess they're saying
like they both had two organizations or
two organized
demonstrations or whatever
both of them have gofundmes this one
there's been like a building set on fire
this one generally no
physical whatever no violence but then
this gofundme was allowed to continue
while this was that's the direct
comparison that's getting the most heat
because
elon musk steps in and he calls them out
with evidence
of times where gofundme itself on their
own accounts were endorsing for people
to donate to uh the blm chop members oh
seattle chop over into the autonomous
zone capitol hill occupied protests
and they were raising funds on gofundme
for uh riot gear protective stuff so
that's already first and people died
inside the chop so then you could do the
same thing the truckers that's happened
in truckers right where you're like well
didn't violence happen like associated
with this and so therefore it validates
the whole movement that movement's
violent right yeah so here's uh elon
musk's uh tweet right here where do you
put amateur thieves and it's the package
stuff on the train and then professional
thieves is go fund me
ah
i hear a lot of shady stuff about
gofundme this is gofundme's uh this is
gofundme's actual tweet
when they were saying to support chop
they said right here in a community with
no police this farmer is feeding people
and bringing them closer together learn
how you can support marcus mission
within the chop so they're actually like
lobbying for people to donate on their
platform did you see chop garden though
did you ever see it i did see a little
bit of it yeah they put cardboard on the
ground
like in like a place with soil put
cardboard down then they put like a
little layer of soil and then they just
put plants they look like [ __ ] so it's
not even so much that like yeah it sucks
without anybody dude when these protests
get out of hand like of course that
sucks for everybody but
it's the double standard within gofundme
that yeah because the main thing here
when there were uh when there was
vandalism and stuff happening during the
blm protest it wasn't the blm marchers
or whatever it was like antifa it was
like [ __ ] vandalism there's just
people [ __ ] it up for everybody but
they didn't get the bad rep they tried
but then people were like look this is a
separation between weirdos coming in
vandalizing looters coming in maybe you
know opportunities yeah right yeah and
then people and then gofundme was like
all right cool how come they don't give
the truckers the same [ __ ] that's weird
standard right that's the absolute devil
that's not fair the thing is i found out
that
a lot of these truckers they're actually
a lot of them were fully vaccinated and
then so they're not some anti-vaxxed
like alt-right group that's like matter
robert malone's like vaccinated but that
doesn't matter he's anti-facts yeah so
then they're so they're trying to paint
them as that but then the message is
being buried because i just took
the original message was uh literally
they're trying to just get to work
without being blocked with the backs or
not backs or whatever right it's also
crazy if
you're vaccinated but you're
anti-mandate then you're also anti-vaxx
yeah right because most people i think
are just anti-mandate they're just i'm
anti-man not [ __ ] vaccinated yeah
same dude yeah just like just give us a
choice we can make our own choices is
what people are fighting for but it's
immediately labeled anti-facts yeah i
don't think it's up to the government to
to to do this you know it's and
especially i feel like if the original
argument which they were like well you
need to protect other people
and also when you take the vaccination
you're not gonna get sick that's what
they were saying in the very beginning
there's news clips out there where
people were all shilling the same story
they used that as a way to say mandate
the vaccinations to protect everybody
else and you can't spread it and you
can't spread it when you get it that's
what they were saying right but now
since all of that [ __ ] is debunked it's
kind of like you could still get it
what so what's the [ __ ] point for the
government to make you take the
vaccinations if you could still spread
it
i don't get it
i don't know well joe it's very simple
um i uh let the news speak for me
can somebody turn on the news
just trust the science right just shut
the [ __ ] up and trust the science and i
guess that's what ethan says
he just says i'm not smart enough to
know so i just listen to whatever the
science has to say as you know and i
guess people could make the argument
like hey if you take the vaccine
vaccination then if you get covet you're
not gonna get it as bad right that's
fine but i also think it's up to the
person's stupidity if they want to die
let them [ __ ] die no one's telling me
it's the same thing as the food right
it's the same if it's gonna be the same
thing as getting a flu shot right where
it's it's literally like the same [ __ ]
where you it's your choice to get it
whether you want to get it or not and if
you get the flu if you get a really bad
flu and you have previous health
conditions and you die that's on you
it's not the government's job to tell
you to [ __ ] take yeah aren't you
killing everybody if you don't get the
vaccination though like aren't you
killing everybody that was the original
argument dude because they were saying
oh you want to get vaccinated then
you're going to spread it how come they
can't update the software now that we
know that that's not the case how come
they can't just go like well okay that's
not the case now it's about this because
nobody has made a statement about it
nobody has gone back on saying hey we
said this we were wrong but this is what
it is like nobody has ever gone out to
make this very clear and the people that
are talking about
the actual
real
application of all this stuff
that nobody really wants to listen to
the rock said it it's all about pride
it's all about power the rock said he'll
say that you know what this reminds me
of it it reminds me of the whole weapons
of mass discretion destruction [ __ ]
right they're going to afghanistan
looking for osama and then they pivot
and go let's go to iraq and everyone's
like wait what
wait what did they find out that like
osama wasn't even from really from
afghanistan like well he's saudi arabia
exactly and it's like this is like all
saudi exactly so everyone's just like
what the [ __ ] is going on but nobody
ever talks about well there's a civil
suit against the saudis because of like
all the 911 damage like hey we're going
to sue the saudi government because [ __ ]
you guys but then our state department
stepped in and said you can't do that
yeah so exactly yeah yeah so gofundme
was flip-flopping over the stance on the
freedom common fundraiser they suspended
them twice
and then uh before ultimately removing
the campaign they uh started refunding
donations before uh they even canceled
this what see that's that's an example
of a centralized protocol and they're
sketched you're super sketchy go dance
or go
so this is one of those situations where
it's like gofundme is supposed to be a
community type of lead initiative where
people can you know outside of the
government can speak their voice in
order to support causes that they
believe and under the stipulation of you
know of course there's got to be some
sort of rules and stuff like that but
it's governed by the people who provide
the money and stuff right so as long as
it isn't causing some sort of harm or
providing finances to something that's
gonna harm other people this is exactly
why we need to have
more centralized places especially when
it comes to the finances because
somebody can come in and have their own
agenda or have their own you know double
standards and whatnot and just be like
push a button nope you're not going to
get the money let's just do this you
know what i mean i like it but do it
with more pop and lock
i like it
dude i've seen people go on gofundme to
be like i'm going to thailand this year
can you can you pay for my [ __ ]
vacation and they post it i've seen that
they should take that [ __ ] down because
that's [ __ ] yeah i mean in a
decentralized place that should also be
fun for a lot of people nah dude [ __ ]
that there were a lot of people during
stop asian hate that were lying and
saying that they were attacked because
of asian hate but it was unconfirmed or
was a [ __ ] total loss yeah there are
lots of ghost gofundme frauds yeah there
was a fraud of this this dude i think he
was like australian or something and
they used a picture of him all [ __ ] up
in a bed all beat up and he was oh he
tried to stand up for an asian elderly
and some guy beat him up and then uh no
record of it and then of course like
[ __ ] tons of asian pages didn't even
really research that [ __ ] and reposting
it
money racked up on that thing and then
only a few of us were like no this
doesn't this seems like [ __ ] and
like i was getting called out for my
comment on it because i wasn't [ __ ]
sensitive and then it turned out it was
a total fraud and they suspended and
deleted the whole [ __ ] and i'm like
[ __ ] asians do better god damn it
like not every one of these is gonna be
every race got somebody who just jumps
the gun yeah
do it with the dance jump the gun bro
jump in the [ __ ] gun we reached so
many new people whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you